j'ai pas l'impression de vendre vos
souvenirs quand vous vendez vos jouets
comme ça non bah c'est pas les meilleurs
tous les enfants Lillois sont passés par
là un jour ils ont vendu leur jouer à la
braderie et avec la cagnotte ils en ont
acheté d'autres la braderie de Lille
c'est un invraisemblable déballage une
tradition qui remonte au Moyen-Âge on
vide les greniers les bibelots les
ustensiles les disques changent de
propriétaire est-ce que vous avez des
moulins à café et des moulins à poivre
il est bien rare de rentrer les mains
vides on finit toujours par craquer pour
quelque chose
de Gaston Leroux et puis on a acheté un
petit œuf à moi collectionnons les œufs
partout on va
juste un petit œuf côté gastronomie la
moule frite reste incontournable devant
les restaurants les coquilles à mon cell
en jeu le titre officieux de plus beau
tas de moules de la braderie c'est pas
mal il y a déjà quatre tonnes un peu
plus de 4 tonnes donc je pense que ce
soir on devrait être 4 tonnes 8 presque